[Music]
this is all the light in the universe
that we can see it's just a fraction of
what's out there
most frequencies of light are actually
invisible to us the light we can see
appears red at its lowest frequencies
and violet at its highest this is called
the visible spectrum and we see it
because cells in our eyes called cones
interpret light reflecting off of
objects we have three different types of
cones that are sensitive to long medium
and short wavelengths of light which
roughly correspond to red green and blue
on the visible spectrum these are the
primary colors of light every other
color is some combination of these three
and that combination is the guiding
principle and colorizing black and white
images
this portrait was taken in 1911 I know
you came here for space photos we're
getting there I promise it's one of the
first examples of color photography and
it's actually three black-and-white
photos composited together Russian
chemist Serge apricot and Gorski took
three identical shots of this man
Alencon using filters for specific
colors of light one allowed red light to
pass through one allowed green and one
allowed blue you can really see how
effective this filter system is when you
compare the red and blue exposures look
how bright Khan's blue robe is in the
photo on the right meaning more of that
color light passed through the filter
dyeing and combining the three negatives
gives you this all right you get the
idea so let's take it into space the
Hubble Space Telescope has been orbiting
Earth since 1990 expanding human vision
into deep space and giving us images
like this one the thing is every Hubble
image you see started out black and
white that's because Hubble's main
function is to measure the brightness of
light reflecting off objects in space
which is clearest in black and white the
color is added later just like the
portrait of Alencon except today
scientists use computer programs like
Photoshop let's use this photo of Saturn
as an example filters separate light
into long medium and short wavelengths
this is called broadband filtering since
it targets general ranges of light each
of the three black and white images are
then assigned a color based on their
position on the visible spectrum the
combined result is a true color image or
what the object would look like if your
eyes were as powerful as a telescope
like Hubble okay now one with Jupiter
see how combining the red and green
brings in yellow and then adding blue
bring cyan and magenta to fully
represent the visible spectrum watch
this animation two more times and I
think you'll see it great now let's add
another level of complexity seeing an
object as it would appear to our eyes
isn't the only way to use color
scientists also use it to map out how
different gases interact in the universe
to form galaxies and nebulae Hubble can
record very narrow bands of light coming
from individual elements like oxygen and
carbon and use color to track their
presence in an image this is called
narrowband filtering the most common
application of narrowband filtering
isolates light from hydrogen sulfur and
oxygen three key building blocks of
stars Hubble's most famous example of
this is called the pillars of creation
which captured huge towers of gas and
dust forming new star systems but this
isn't a true color image like the one of
Saturn from before it's more of a
colorized map hydrogen and sulfur are
both seen naturally in red light and
oxygen is more blue coloring these gases
as we'd actually see them would produce
red red and cyan and the pillars of
creation would look more like this not
as useful for visual analysis in order
to get a full-color image and visually
separate the sulfur from the hydrogen
scientists assign the elements to red
green and blue according to their place
in the chromatic order basically that
means that since oxygen has the highest
frequency of the three it's assigned to
blue and since hydrogen is red but a
higher frequency than sulfur it gets
green the result is a full-color image
mapping out the process by which our own
solar system might have formed
[Music]
the Hubble Space Telescope can record
light outside of the visible spectrum -
in the ultraviolet and near-infrared
bands
an infrared image of the pillars of
creation for example looks very
different the longer wavelengths
penetrate the clouds of dust and gas
that block out visible light frequencies
revealing clusters of stars within it
and beyond these images showing in
visible light are colored the same way
multiple filtered exposures are assigned
a color based on their place in the
chromatic order lowest frequencies get
red middle get green highest get blue
which could beg the question are the
colors real yes and no the color
represents real data and it's used to
visualize the chemical makeup of an
object or an area in space helping
scientists see how gases interact
thousands of light-years away giving us
critical information about how stars and
galaxies form over time so even if it
isn't technically how our eyes would
perceive these objects it's not made up
either the color creates beautiful
images but more importantly it shows us
the invisible parts of our universe
you